a new poll has come out and it should
surprise no one it shows that about half
the country thinks that in their
lifetime in the us there will be a civil
war and that more than half of democrats
and republicans believe america will
cease to exist as a democracy now i know
it's a bit cliche tim cast iral tim
poole coming on saying civil war he
screams into the microphone but there's
a reason we're doing this because today
we're being joined by dennis prager and
we didn't want to just do the typical
like here's the news let's talk we want
to have a deeper conversation of the
conflict happening in this country what
what is currently going on around it and
we'll talk about a variety of issues as
to why it's happening potential
solutions and just have a deeper
conversation than just jumping from
story to story so without further ado
joining us is dennis prager great to be
with you
one of the reasons aside obviously from
being with you
i just want to note uh that my son is a
huge fan of yours and for a good part of
a year said dad you've got to go on tim
wow awesome glad
i'm honored and privileged
to uh to have you it is an honor and a
privilege to have you here and i think
it's gonna be even before the show
started i kept having to tell like ian
like calm down don't yeah so many
questions you're saying so much um
interesting and amazing things is gonna
be a really fun conversation so
we'll talk about that we do have a bunch
of news that will will likely come up of
course outside of just this poll we have
um in in this vein of civil wars i feel
that 17 pregnancy centers have been
firebombed correct this is absolutely
insane because this this strikes the
heart of
what the actual goal of the
establishment in the left is when it
comes to abortion it's certainly not
helping underprivileged women have
children so we'll we'll get into all
this stuff as part of the larger
conversation we also got luke rudkowski
and it's only going to get more insane
dennis thank you so much for coming on
my name is lukedowski of we are
change.org i am your humble t-shirt
vendor today i have a visual
representation of what's happening to
the american people it's a shirt that
says that you will own nothing and be
happy and it has a representation of
klaus schwab committing armed robbery
against you uh so if you like that
t-shirt you can get it on
thebestpoliticoshirts.com and because
you do i'm here thanks so much for
having me shout out to things getting
more insane uh i want to show you guys
someone sent this to me look at this
it's jesus this is crazy giant-sized
crossland so epic thank you for sending
that out and um let's get rolling dennis
because i want to hear some more stuff
for those that live in new york city if
you go to times square you can see a
giant billboard with ian on it it's live
back
well actually it it cycles between me
luke and michael malus and then always
you and then you're like on the
billboard right next to it right so it's
always like back that's pretty cool oh
yeah yeah absolutely yeah dude i'm
looking forward to talking about
communism and i didn't know until
tonight that you had studied it so in
depth in depth that was my field of
study and the sad part is i never
thought it would be relevant to america
i studied it in order to understand our
enemy in the cold war so i studied
russian i went to communist countries
almost every year
and
lo and behold
the the threat is very real in our
country i i must admit although i have a
very somber view of mankind
i really did believe that this was the
land of the free and the home of the
brave
forever that free this is the land of
free speech why we got the statue of
liberty france didn't give it to belgium
or germany or england or anybody else
we deserved it i didn't think free
speech would be threatened in america
and it is and that's the that's the most
important freedom and that's the first
thing that they suppress along with guns
as it happens absolutely we'll get in
all that stuff we got lydia pressing the
buttons i'm also here in the corner that
is where i like to push buttons i'm
stoked for tonight it's gonna be a great
crossover episode dennis has so much to
say and i'm thrilled to hear hear it all
before we get started my friends head
over to timcasta.com and become a member
to help support our work at timcast.com
you'll get exclusive members only
segments from this show we put those up
monday through thursday at 11 p.m so
we're gonna have one of those up tonight
we also have a whole bunch of
journalists and as a member you're
helping support their work
and you'll also be supporting our
infrastructure as you know we use rumble
infrastructure for the back end and for
our video player so that we can be more
resilient against censorship and
actively defy silicon valley and the big
tech sensors i know we're still on
youtube but don't worry we are working
on it actively behind the scenes there's
only so much we can do but we do have
some announcements coming soon it's
gonna be a whole lot of fun we'll see
how things play out but for the meantime
don't forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
with your friends let's jump to this
first story something interesting to
kick off this greater conversation the
daily mail reports more than half of
democrats and republicans believe
america will cease to exist as a
democracy according to a new poll they
also go on to say the poll found the
majority of republicans 52 percent say
that it's likely there will be a civil
war in the u.s in their lifetime while
half of independence 50 percent and a
plurality of democrats 46 percent agree
the poll surveyed 1
541 adults and was conducted from june
10th
on uh
from june 10th the day of the healing uh
hearing
the january 6 hearing until june 13th it
also found americans have largely given
up on one another
so before the show you know we we
normally would do is we would pull up
like the biggest most relevant story and
issues around it and uh we decided we do
something inverted and we would talk
with dennis prager about what's going on
why people are
experiencing this first from your point
of view and then have that actually lead
into the news stories as opposed to the
way around so
this isn't the first poll we've seen
where people think civil war is coming
we also had a poll that came out or i
should say a survey that came out from
the splc whether you trust him or not
i'm not a big fan but it showed that the
younger generation is more likely to
support political assassination and
revolution my view is
once the older generation ages out as it
were either leaves the political uh the
political fight altogether or passes on
the next generations are going to be
increasingly more prone to violence
which ultimately will lead to
civil war violence i'm curious as to
your thoughts why pete why you think
people feel this way or what do you
think has happened that's causing it
so let me give you an example
and i don't know how this registers with
you uh because i remember when i was a
kid and i would hear
older people say you know when i was a
kid
and i don't remember how i reacted
either i reacted oh i'm very curious to
know what it was like when you were a
kid or
gee i've heard that before happy but
i'll take that risk when i was a kid
there was one truly given in this
country you could say whatever you
wanted and i remember it because
i would play i grew up in brooklyn new
york and we'd play stickball i have no
idea if you even know what stickball is
tell me no come on you're not going to
do it
what stickball oh yeah
baseball
no sorry they didn't call it baseball
well of course it was baseball but it
was called stickball because you played
with a stick we didn't have a bat in the
street we had a and it was a rubber ball
what neighborhood in brooklyn uh
flatbush
anyway where the brooklyn dodgers were
so anyway uh this is what would happen
some kid would start screaming at
another kid and the other kid would go
oh shut up and then that kid would say
uh i could say whatever i want this is
america
that was a common
uh rebuttal to anybody who said shut up
we said that when we were kids okay so
great even better so that's even better
all right
that is that is no longer said by kids
uh you could say whatever you want this
is america has been shattered by the
left and i just want to make something
clear because i'll use the term left
fair a number of times i don't believe
that left and liberal are the same i
have 32 differences in one column
differences between left and liberal
people could easily look it up
dennis prager differences between left
liberal i did a prageru video on it in
five minutes i'll just give you one
example
liberals believe in racial integration
and leftists believe in racial
segregation agreed okay there's a
there's an all-black dorm at columbia
where i went there's an all-black
graduation at columbia where i went uh
that uh there are only two groups who
support all black dorms
uh leftists and the ku klux klan just
for the record it's really important
that people understand liberals don't
support it and conservatives don't
support it
so uh the the the ascendance of the left
is the descent of all these freedoms and
that that is the root of it
if they allowed us to be heard
we
we would not
be confronting the possibility of civil
war we would change so many minds but
they
they make it almost impossible for us to
be heard
and that that is the great battle that
is why what what the what google youtube
uh twitter etc what they have done is is
so injurious to the society it's a
revolution
their their their goal as it was
explained to me is
minimize the right just enough not to
cause a splash but to make them
ineffective in politics so you censor
enough people so that the conversation
will be 60 percent left and 40 right and
then what happens is you give it time
and over time the right loses the
argument because they've they've got no
foot in the battle in the battlefield
and i'll give you another interesting
thing that people don't reflect on
we ache to have them on our shows
we ache to debate them
but they won't debate us and they won't
come on our shows and they want us have
us on their shows i have offered tens of
thousands of dollars to any left-wing
columnist on the new york times to
debate me anywhere they want they could
choose the moderator they could choose
the audience and serious money
uh uh and that's 99 of the new york
times columnists are leftists maybe
there are three that are not non-left uh
but they would never do it i ache to
debate
uh with them would i would raise a
hundred thousand dollars probably i
could probably raise that to have
tanahisi coats or ibram x candy debate
larry elder okay it would end the career
of tanahisi coats or ibrahimovic they
know that they would be regarded as the
moral and intellectual frauds that they
are larry would wipe the floor with them
uh uh i could give you five black
intellectuals who would wipe the floor
with them that's the whole that's that's
the key to their success
is not enabling us to have an audience
but you see it seems that they target
what we would refer to as npcs are you
familiar with the term no non-player
characters people who don't take an
active role and don't care and just say
tell me what to believe and tell me how
to fit in
so
you take a look at
well i'll give you the example i love to
give we can start with the trayvon
martin story which was not true hands up
don't shoot that was not true uh ahmed
arby's story that was not true russia
gate ukraine gate jesse smallett i think
the president said they were good nazis
that there were fine nazis the launching
of joe biden's campaign not true and so
when they come out and they say we're
the good guys trust us don't listen to
them and we come out and we say please
listen to everything they have to say
and then have a conversation with us the
people who are interested in saying i
want to know for myself they'll come and
take a look and watch the video and say
oh okay dennis is clearly right on those
issues they'll the people who don't want
to do that say look man i just want to
fit in i'm going to do whatever they
tell me i think what we're seeing now is
largely the separation is i described
this four years ago i called it the
uninitiated and the politically
discerning people who will look at a
story and say is that true let me check
and the people who say i don't know it's
probably true media said it
those people just blindly follow the
narrative of the establishment media
they believe fake news every single time
i should say the overwhelming majority
of them just believe whatever the tv
says even though it's proven wrong over
and over again and then you have the
other side which includes
traditional liberals libertarians
moderates conservatives those are all
right wing what i i facetiously say what
makes you right wing is knowing facts
reality has a conservative bias stephen
colbert he said that line i'm sure
you're familiar with reality as a
liberal bias you know 20 or so years ago
but now the issue is if someone comes
out and says oh did you know that hunter
biden was on the board of barisma and
was receiving 83 000 a month and that
joe biden intervened with the quid pro
quo to withhold u.s guaranteed aid to
the government unless the government did
him a favor to stop and uh to fire this
prosecutor just so happened the
prosecutor was investigating the company
where his son worked if you say that
your right wing regardless of your
politics so if you know the facts you're
right-wing
a guy came over to me at an airport
right before the lockdowns by the way i
i hope you'll all adopt this i never say
before covid i say before lockdowns
yeah covet is not the issue it was the
reaction the destruction
was the lockdowns
anyway so about a few months before the
lockdowns at philadelphia airport i
recall well
the guy comes over to me and
thank god people come over to me
at every airport except boston
interestingly i don't have any fans in
boston
but anyway guy comes over to me and and
i'm a heterosexual guy so it's not often
that i think well this guy's really good
looking this guy was really good looking
i'm six foot four
not as good looking as this guy this guy
was six foot four comes over with a
minimal accent minimal and tells me oh i
really love your work and i go where are
you from he goes norway i said oh you
watch prageru in norway oh yeah all the
time i go really you're a you're a
norwegian conservative
and he said to me this was priceless
apropos of what you just said
and he said
i i don't i don't know if i'm
conservative i just follow logic
[Laughter]
and i said then you're conservative
that's how it goes these days that's how
it goes let me give a uh
to reiterate my point um
here's a guy who just
sees you tell the fact and says
interesting and you would be in the
united states that's conservative
that's right yeah that's exactly it
i would like to know what position i
hold that is not directed by morality
and logic i'd like to know one
position that i hold and i would
probably drop it if if logic and
morality do not dictate that position
i hereby announce i will drop it i'll
tell you we had a we had a fun time we
had a progressive on the show a couple
weeks ago
and it was uh sheamus coughlin of
freedom tunes who's a cr
he's a catholic conservative
uh pro-life there's me which uh i guess
uh disaffected liberal post liberal
whatever they call it and um you know
moderately pro-choice and then this
progressive who was pro-abortion up to
the point of birth or maybe beyond and
it was funny because sheamus backed off
he was just like he let me you know and
this guy had this discussion and then
eventually i said to him i was like this
is the crazy thing you know i asked him
do you believe abortion should be uh the
woman's choice up to the point of birth
or should be allowed legal and he said
women's choice and i was like the woman
is about to give birth to a baby at nine
months gestation and the baby can be
terminated killed ripped out and he goes
woman's choice and i'm like okay well i
come from a traditional liberal
background where we're like
you know maybe after the fetus is viable
you just save it you don't have to kill
it right and then i was like but isn't
it strange that i am a pro-choice
liberal and you're calling me right wing
and you're arguing for abortion to the
point of birth
how is that the liberal position how is
how is that we're in this argument and
the actual conservative over here is
keeping his mouth shut it's just the
whole as you mentioned the left and
liberal being different yeah you got to
be careful with labels relying too much
on labels and what they mean to you
because they might mean something
different to someone else but it's the
facts and beliefs that are really
important well that's why it's important
to define as i did i i i as i said i
have an article with 32 distinctions
and and
the the race one is one of the biggest
we believe in integrate we believe
we do believe
liberals
i was raised i'm a jew from new york by
definition a liberal and i was raised
that race blind is the moral ideal
you don't see a person's race you see
their character you see their
personality you see their brains you see
everything and and
so i i
today race is determinative which is
mind-boggling because
i ask
leftist one question if you know a
person is black
tell me one other thing you know about
them
and they can't name a thing do you know
whether they're kind or despicable do
you know whether they're honest or
crooked do you know whether they are
interesting or boring do you know
whether they are
uh liberal or conservative you know
nothing when you know someone's skin
color you can tell more about a person
by their shoes than you can by their
race that's that's perfectly said yeah
let me let me let me do this we'll give
a shout out to this famous video that
i've been dying to to talk to you about
bill maher
you were on you on real time with bill
maher what was this like 2017 or 20 no
no no it was actually 2019. 20 which is
even more remarkable how recent
so you were on uh with bill maher and
you you mentioned that there are uh
tampons in the men's restrooms at
universities
and bill the panel and the audience
that's why i said men menstruate is a
left-wing lie right okay and then they
all started laughing and bill maher goes
what
what are you doing
and you were like it's in the news look
it up and they were like no and you were
like they have tampons in the men's room
and bill goes it's for their girlfriends
remarkable the arrogance and ignorance
at the same time
instead of just being like
i'm i gotta call here's what i'd say if
you said something to me that i thought
was wrong i'd pull it up and if we were
on a show like that i would be like
are you serious with this is this true
can we get someone to check that and
guess what they would have done they had
to come back and be like he's right
right correct
well i it was a great moment because the
entire panel
bill maher and the entire audience
laughed at me
and uh just for the record i actually
enjoy that i'm not a masochist
but
when i know i'm right and you have a
whole bunch of people laughing at you
it is so revealing as to how easily
people are brainwashed
that that's the reason that i liked it
that
that audience didn't hear it from the
new york times so it didn't happen
that that
they as i say on my radio show almost
every day
they don't know that is the left they
don't know what we know well so uh i
pulled up the article because we
actually did a segment on it it's an old
article this is an article from the
daily beast which is fake news by the
way newsguard says they're fake news um
published september 21st 2016 which is
titled yes men can have periods and we
need to talk about them
so
2016 you go on bill maher's show three
years right later years
so that's why i say it's it's left and
right in this country is do you read the
news or are you just an arrogant also it
shows you this is a very important
lesson the speed with which the left can
have people say
wet is dry
this is this that was october
uh or or november of 2019 wow
and within a year and a half if you said
men do not menstruate you were
considered a hater
that is how fast the left changes half
this country's views on a equals b
equals c this is the issue i i i
this is the issue i have with bill maher
right i do appreciate that he's called
out woke nonsense that he believes in
free speech but the man doesn't do
research
i i i don't know is he retired
you know is is this you know i i i say
retired in the sense that he's phoning
it in he shows up he says give me the
cue cards he sits down and he says i'm
gonna buy i didn't read that and it's
like bill this story is three and a half
years old if you don't know about this
that's your fault not mine how could a
guy have one of the he has a million
viewers per night when he does a show
per night you know per show which is
weekly and this guy didn't bother
to read the news three and a half years
ago i mean this story has been extremely
prominent it's not this one article i've
pulled up the issue surrounding this has
been going on for quite some time the
issues surrounding racial segregation
has been happening over and over and
over again you would have to actively
ignore the news to not know these things
yeah i just want to say uh that
it's so rare to have a liberal call out
the left
that i i want i want to salute him as
you pointed out yourself he he does call
out wokeness uh but you you you would
think he would have known it that is
correct i think it's an example of kind
of the old media model of like let's
have an interview and dan be the
consequences versus the new model of
let's have access to the internet and
look it up and fact check in real time
like rogan never would have had a hit
show if he didn't have someone looking
up the facts he would have just been
wrong a bunch and looked like an idiot
well i think the biggest thing is
admitting that you're wrong and i think
that's the biggest difference between
individuals online and there are a lot
of individuals predominantly who are
promoted by big tech social media that
never admit that they are wrong bill
maher just a couple weeks ago was
talking about how the economy is doing
great we're in a recovery everything's
fine the the right wingers are are being
sensationalistic when it comes to the
dire economic numbers and here we are
sitting with the calamity that that
we're facing uh that is absolutely
unavoidable right now is he going to to
talk about his mistakes probably not and
and you know i'll give you my thoughts
on this we mentioned this the other day
we had jamie kilstein on he's a he's a
liberal comedian i guess but he was
canceled and you know came after him so
he's like formerly woke and we were
talking about the red flag laws
and i said red flag laws it's stop and
frisk on steroids so i'm at occupy wall
street jamie's at occupy wall street
luke's down there and across the
spectrum where like stop and frisk is a
bad thing what they were doing you're
familiar with stop and frisk of course
so it turns out according to a few
whistleblowers that the mayor actually
ordered the police or i should say the
police were ordered to specifically
target racial minorities and the
justification was well that's the
demographic committing the crime
and the response on the left was like if
it's the neighborhood perhaps but to
come out blanket just be like no it was
the racial group so we were like
these terry stops are a violation of
your of your fourth amendment rights
regardless i'm not a fan red flag laws
are the same thing but now they can go
into your house how was it that the left
and liberals were like stop and frisk is
wrong and morally repugnant but red flag
laws it's even worse but we should have
that there's no logical consistency to
what they're arguing for so you know
we're talking with jamie and his his
attitude is like i didn't think about it
that way but you're right
stop and frisk was a bad thing why would
the left be championing for something
worse than it was the same thing
the left doesn't think
about right and wrong it thinks about
it
morality separates this is this is my
field as it were
the moral
outlook on life is what is right what is
wrong what is good what is bad
the left since lenin really since marx
never asked that
it doesn't divide the world between good
and bad it divides the world between
rich and poor black and white
strong and weak
male and female
imperialist versus victim
that does not those are its divisions
not good and bad
i knew i learned this at columbia when i
was told by every single professor i had
it is not possible to be a black racist
it is not possible when was that what oh
this 1970s wow
so
a lot of this stuff is not new it's
worse than ever it's more absurd than
ever but it's not new that is a very
important statement a black cannot be a
racist it means moral criteria do not
apply where there's a racial criterion
race trumps morality economics trump
morality power trumps morality morality
is not a left-wing consideration and and
those of us who think
in normal terms wait there's right and
wrong a black could be a racist the
white could be a racist the black could
be beautiful or white could be beautiful
no that is none left thinking right i
don't know if you
some people say left some people say
people who are indoctrinated and don't
critically think there was an incredible
video that that was highlighted that i
that i played on on one of my members
areas uh today specifically highlighting
a young man at an abortion rally
specifically women who are arguing for
abortion for women's reproductive rights
and he asked him my body my choice all
of them said absolutely a hundred
percent and then he asked him where did
you stand on the mandates just a few
months ago and all of them
yeah with the vaccine mandates
specifically and all of them had this
moment of uh but
that's different
that's what they said yeah that's that's
different one woman the last one was
funny she goes i'm not talking about
that exactly but the principles the
morals there you know they're
inconsistent they're they're absolutely
illogical that people are not critically
thinking they're being swayed by
emotional mind control that's telling
them what they should be believing and
pushing for fitting in
tribe cult
most of these default liberal types just
want to fit in so whatever the machine
tells them they say okay
then you have the left which has seized
the reins of the machine and they're
just thrown out edict so is communism
the easiest thing to fit into like
politically geopolitically um
as opposed to like because it's not easy
to be an american that's constantly
freaking out about freedom and like
always so here's a very
big deal that i i
realized early in my life
uh liberty is not a human yearning
it is not a human instinct
it is a it is a value that has to be
learned and taught
the uh the the human instinct is to be
taken care of and people will most
hum
most human beings
would prefer to be taken care of than to
be free
that that's that's the way it is and
that is the reason the left wins every
almost everywhere in the world
how many american liberty countries are
there in in in the western hemisphere
outside of the united states
canada used to be one not not any longer
and
that's what humans humans make the deal
i'll give you my freedom you give me
free health care i'll give you my
freedom you give me free education give
me free give me free give me free you
can have my freedom but you know if you
really look at it from
an evolutionary psychological
perspective it makes sense that's right
that's the reason you need a a higher
principle than evolution to guide your
life by which is why ultimately i do
believe this is a religious battle let's
let's talk about that too because um
one of my views there's a lot of people
who've described what the difference
between the left and the right is some
have said it's national nationalist
versus a globalist i don't think that's
that's correct it's a component some
have said it's authoritarian versus
libertarian it's a component some have
said interestingly we had stephen marsh
on the show he wrote the book the next
civil war and he said it's
in the united states there is a
multicultural democracy and a
constitutional republic
both can't co-exist in the same country
and i'm like that's an interesting way
to put it actually but maybe just one
component i believe uh and i mentioned a
moment ago that it's the politically
discerning those who would challenge the
news and try and make sure they're
correct versus those who want to follow
and fit in i think one large component
is
the christian moral framework versus
an absent moral framework and what i
mean by that is to go back to bill maher
the way i've described in the past bill
maher is an atheist he made the
documentary religious where he
challenges you know he asks people he
travels around trying to understand
bill maher will say he doesn't believe
in god as morality doesn't come from
that but his morality literally is based
in the bible not completely not all of
it i'm not saying that and i'm not
saying you need to be religious because
i'm not practicing religious in any way
any religion what i mean is why do we
have the value of innocent until proven
guilty
because we were raised by a culture that
valued that if you were raised in a
different culture on the side of the
planet they would not have the same
value in fact there have been many
countries that have said the inverse it
is better that 10 innocent people suffer
than one guilty person escape we in the
united states hold an inverted view of
that benjamin franklin said it is better
that 100 guilty persons escaped than one
innocent person suffer he was it was a
plan blackstone's formulation which is
10 people blackstone's formulation it is
better that 10 guilty persons escaped
than one innocent suffer is rooted in
the story of sodom and gomorrah
literally in the bible when when god
says to lot if there's about one
righteous person i want to abraham to
abraham there you go so you know more
than i do about that stuff but um i read
about this because i wanted to
understand why do we have these values
in this country and so i read about the
fourth and fifth amendment i read about
the the presumption of innocence i read
some of the writings from the founding
fathers and their views on it benjamin
franklin i read the praise for
blackstone's formulation
and then i discovered his formulation
was rooted in the bible and i said
that's fascinating these stories from
religion were carried on and left within
us by the the previous generation now
people like bill maher say they don't
believe in any of that stuff not
realizing
he would have never known of that
concept were it not passed down to him
when you look at other countries other
cultures on the other side of the planet
that did not have the same religious
values they don't have this if you look
at what's going on with communist china
and
other countries they have a presumption
of guilt you get locked up and then
we'll figure it out
so in this country it seems like there
came a point where we still are mostly
christian but many people aren't really
practicing and don't really know what it
means you get a generation of people who
say they're atheists but still hold a
lot of those christian moral for a lot
of that christian moral framework and
now we're entering a period where you
have a generation with no moral
framework at all and if there's no moral
framework then there is no truth but
power which is what we're starting to
see lie cheat and steal say whatever you
want get political power that's the path
and that's what i see with the
mainstream left the modern left today
every word you said is correct
my first book i wrote when i was 25 it's
still the most widely read introduction
to judaism in english
and in it i wrote about something i had
read called cut flower ethics
if you cut flowers from the soil that
nurtured them
you could look at the flower and for a
couple of days it looks like it doesn't
need the soil that nurtured it
but it will wither and die
the same with ethics in the western
world they were nurtured in religious
judeo-christian soil you rip those
ethics from that soil they will last for
a generation or two just like the flower
will for a day or two and then they will
wither and die and that is exactly what
we are seeing happening now
and that is why the founders of the
country wrote that we have inalienable
rights from the creator there are no
inalienable rights from human beings
there are only inalienable rights if
there is something that transcends the
the human and that is the creator
the most hated video i ever made i know
it because i actually look at comments
i'm fascinated by comments
and the most hated and i and i have
hundreds and hundreds out there
including 50 at prageru where we have
over 500 i do one out of ten
the most hated video i ever made was
uh i don't remember the exact title but
essentially if god did not say murder is
wrong is murder wrong
and it drives people crazy even though
the logic
i debated this at oxford many years ago
against the professor of moral
philosophy at oxford and he's an atheist
and he said of course prager is right if
there is no god there is no objective
morality only only subjective you can
say i believe murder is wrong i think
murder is wrong i feel murder is wrong
but you can't say murder is wrong
only if there is something that
transcends the human that says murder is
wrong is murder wrong
but how do you explain that to someone
who doesn't have the mental capacity to
understand it
or you mean a college graduate
is that it that is the definition of not
having the mental capacity i'm not being
cute i i have said for years and i do
believe this sincerely for most people
not all
college makes you stupid oh i agree uh
i'm a high school dropout and the funny
thing is you are yes you made my day
i'm not joking
well so the left
they believe in credentialism and so
they'll often say don't listen to tim
who is a high school dropout that means
he's dumb and my attitude is like my
arguments are what proves i'm dumb like
if you think my arguments are bad and
they are bad then i'm dumb but if you
don't have an argument against what i've
said or you don't understand the
concepts behind them because you like
the mental capacity i don't think the
issue is credentials or school i think
in my experience you can argue that many
high school dropouts tend not to succeed
but there are a lot of people who
realize
the system isn't working properly and in
my case i was building computers
programming video games i was playing
music and i just thought this does not
serve me in any way other than to drag
me down and so i just you know took
issue with it well i mean
sorry i i just call them indoctrination
centers that's exactly what they are and
i would just kind of want to point out
also there's a lot of statistics when it
comes to people who believe in religion
people who have families and correlation
with not just overall happiness but
success in in life that i think are
absolutely worth talking about here as
well that provide a lot of different
perspective when it comes to you know a
lot of people coming up in this world i
wanna i wanna mention when you say uh
what cut flower is that what you called
it yeah cut flower ethics yeah that's
brilliant it perfectly describes it
perfectly that uh that's bill maher to
the teeth the way i see him that's right
he doesn't understand that his values
actually he's living on borrowed on
borrowed soil and the woke is a direct
result of his advocacy of rejecting this
moral framework
again i'm not saying that people need to
believe in god but i think you need to
understand your roots and where your
values come from so by the way forgive
me i just want to say to the chagrin of
many religious people
uh i almost only argue for the necessity
of god rather than the existence of god
because if i prove to you or not you
can't prove it but if i convince you god
exists i have done nothing but if i c
because the the number of people who
believe in god who are moral idiots is
very large
however
if i convince you that god is morally
necessary and is necessary for meaning
in life the greatest urge human has he
has even more so than sex
then i have changed your life well this
is what's fascinating um and as i've
looked at the the ethos and the tenets
of the modern left there seems to be no
moral framework at all and they say
there is one but i'll give the example
of stop and frisk in red flag laws stop
and frisk new york said we want to stop
guns on the street and contraband
therefore the police now have the right
to randomly stop anyone and frisk them
it resulted in marginalized people as
the left said and it literally did
disproportionately targeted uh young
black men and latinos the argument from
bloomberg was they're the ones
committing the crime so that's what
you're gonna see now the whistle blowing
was that they actually were instructed
to target racial minorities so they kind
of leap frogged the the issue of here's
where the crime is to just target the
racial group and that had a negative
consequence if that issue was bad red
flag laws exact same logic we got to get
guns off the street and stop danger
people from having them we can go into
your home and take your guns if we have
reason to believe that you're you know
unwell or a threat or a danger
if that happens in new york and it
happens in a bunch of place which i
think it already has you're going to
start seeing the exact same thing they
were already complaining about
if they say one is good and one is bad
but they're functionally identical or
one is actually
red flag laws are worse much worse but
they want them and stop and frisk is is
not as bad but it's the it's the it's
apocalyptic there's no moral logic
behind what they're arguing for in which
case i don't know the point
if you know i i think stop-and-frisk is
wrong beyond there okay so to to just
reinforce your point npr during 2020 or
2021 i assume 2020
actually devoted an hour
to a a woman who wrote a book
in defense of looting i i'm familiar um
correct i gotta tell you i was in
ferguson do not steal does not apply
if if you are
as i said
they don't divide the world between
right and wrong but between black and
white rich and poor if a black person
loots it's okay except in that community
because what really angered me about
that i'm fairly certain that article was
about ferguson
and what happened was
i was in ferguson and i watched a group
of young black men link arms to protect
a store from looters
and when they were asked by a journalist
from al jazeera
why are you defending this store they
said we live here this is our community
these are our stores the people who are
looting don't live here and they are
robbing us they are stealing from us and
in many instances it's yuppies looting
it's right like the lawyers in new york
city that just by the way had their
charges dropped that firebombed a police
car so i'm in ferguson i know that
really yep the people who were looting
in ferguson didn't live there many of
most of them and the these poor people
who lived in this area desperately
trying to protect their own stores from
an outside force destroying it and then
these leftists write articles defending
those who actually
attacked the black community that that
to me was one of the most despicable
displays i have ever seen to see these
young men say we're trying to do right
by our community and then they have them
right none of the looting is good
those young men were being robbed their
their community was being destroyed they
needed someone to come in and say stop
these violent riders and looters from
destroying these people's neighborhood
instead they said well it's actually a
good thing because they're doing it as
an act of rebellion against white
supremacy feels like moral relativism
may be i think are you saying you may be
indicating that there's a moral absolute
this this but if there's no moral
absolute then
then it's then murder isn't wrong i'm
thinking about the romans emperor
constantine he basically became the
first christian which was rooted in
judaism which is thou shall not kill but
he went and killed eastward
and conquered and murdered the fact that
people don't live by their own values
does not mean that the values are
irrelevant
you are right you could point to any
number of religious people who have
screwed up their own religion that is
correct but you can't live without the
principles the
in other words a lot of christians kept
slaves but it was and this is a jew
saying it was christians who abolished
slavery not muslims not shintoists not
confucianists not hindus
and not atheists it was christians who
abolished uh slavery on planet earth is
it the situation where the tenets of
judaism that the ten commandments are
good to follow unless fill in the blank
i uh you you you're really uh playing to
my
passion
my life is devoted to having people live
by the ten commandments i have a great
new saying you wanna you wanna defund
the police have everybody live by the
ten commandments i want to give an
example if i may because uh behind me
i'm told is my one of my volumes of my
bible commentary
if if every atheist listening read that
they would at least intellectually
appreciate what those of us who believe
the bible is the greatest book ever
written is about has nothing to do with
faith nothing that's why i call it the
rational bible
and uh i i begin my my preface as
follows when i was in my early twenties
and late teens i had issues with my
parents which is pretty common on earth
however i i honored my parents i showed
them respect
all the time i never deviated from that
and there was a reason and it was the
only reason i believed that god himself
had commanded me
to honor your father and mother i
believed i would be sinning against god
forget my parents
if i didn't show my parents honor even
if i had a hard time with them and i'm
telling you
this this is a classic example of what
the left is doing to the society by
getting rid of of the of the of the ten
commandments the divine origins of all
this
what we're seeing today is this is my my
field of study communism and fascism for
that matter and nazism
every totalitarian movement begins by by
subverting parental authority and that
is what the left is doing in america
you're subverting parental authority
you listen to the state
kids you listen to the leader kids you
don't listen to your parents kids oh
yeah and also a lot of authority figures
so when the russians the soviets took
over poland they got rid of a lot of
doctors they got rid of a lot of
teachers they got rid of a lot of
lawyers they got rid of a lot of
historians and just took them to siberia
or assassinated them because they were
the ones that were the most influential
in their society and they needed to get
rid of that in order to push the
communist doctrine and you know you know
it's brutal here i want to address that
there's uh i grew up in in a
neighborhood chicago that had a lot of
polish people there's a lot of polish
jokes stereotypes about people being
dumb
talking to luke it's a particularly
brutal origin the reason that stereotype
exists is because soviets killed all the
intellectuals well and then
by the way somewhat of a farce i
remember when when polish jokes were in
so i have two comments on that first i
studied in england
my junior year in college every single
polish joke i heard in america was an
english joke about the irish right who
would not be not known thank you so much
there's another one
at the very time people were telling the
most polish jokes the brilliant pope was
polish pope pope john xxiii or is it
john paul ii john paul
one of the most brilliant men of of that
generation and uh lequalensa was polish
and and and carter's uh
head of security was big neil brzezinski
polish who was the guy i studied under
at columbia ironically but uh
i don't understand why polish jokes ever
developed uh national it was it was
against just demeaning the people and um
actually police people actually have
some of the highest iq in the region
spiegel brzezinski the national security
advisor i actually had some very
interesting conversations with him on my
own personal channel but there's a lot
we could get into especially culturally
especially with poland but i also have
another question to ask about the larger
religious aspect just kind of debate
this because the left usually also has a
counter argument to what we're talking
about now and their arguments i don't
know how you would address this but they
usually say religion isn't good it
created war it created suffering it
created the crusades and historically
they would argue that it was a net
negative how you how do you respond
how bad our
education is in america
the most the bloodiest century on record
is the 20th century
and that is because a hundred million
people non-combatants were murdered
non-combatants forget war
99 of them except for the case of the of
the of the turks killing armenians
99 of that 100 million were killed by
secular regimes
they never tell you that they thought oh
all the evil committed by religious
groups
first of all everybody was religious in
the middle ages so it's it's it's a
pointless point all the good done was
also done by religious groups all the
bad that's all you had were religious
groups but where you had religious and
secular there is no comparison
the death of god is the death of man
sorry that's why i say i i am i'm
interested in
in arguing for god's existence but i am
passionate about the importance of
talking about god's necessity yeah we i
think a lot of the issue they're having
is that the i think the commandments
some of them are plaintive like don't
kill people don't murder don't do your
buddy's wife like got it okay yeah let's
live peacefully but they don't like the
authority they're radical right yes the
authority of religion that's right
organization am my authority that's
correct and if i don't want to treat my
parents right who the f is god to tell
me i have to and then the state will
slide in and co-opt that and the
corporation unfocused
need for authority because we we're we
live with this libertarian authority
bent that's constantly wavering but we
need we have parents we can't get by
without some authority in the early days
or probably the whole time i think the
one of the challenges is that
i don't i don't know if you have to
believe it i don't think you believe in
god i think you need to understand the
philosophy and the philosophy philosophy
behind the religions understand the
history of humanity how we came to the
point what religion provided and then
you can be someone who is a secular
atheist and say i understand like i
mentioned with the with the innocent
until proven guilty why it's valuable
how it helps civilization how it's
rooted in religion if a secular atheist
says look i personally i just find it
very hard to believe in god for xyz
reasons however
if mankind gives that up
if the bible is not the reference point
we're screwed
i have no issue with that but they
replaced that with star wars if you see
a lot of young men they have replaced
cartoons fictional characters
entertainment movie hollywood psyops as
i call them with this worshiping idea of
these fake characters these fake idols
and they make their whole lives
surrounded with their personalities
around these fake figures so so there is
some kind of merit to the argument that
if they're not going to have you know a
religious belief they're going to have a
belief implanted by corporations inside
their minds is secularized religion all
of it that is exactly what it is uh uh
gk chesterton has the best line of all
not at late 19th century british uh
brilliant mind he said when people stop
believing in god they don't believe in
nothing they believe in anything that's
true we are you're familiar with peter
pagosian i'd imagine yep uh he i had a
great conversation with him several
years ago about intersectionality as the
new non-theistic religion
and as we know where that evolved today
it's basically wokism leftism it is a
group of people who have
they have a non-theistic religion the
way the way i view it i once read this
book on uh simulating elements it was a
physics book it talked about how they
used a circuit board sending electrons
down a path and they created something
that ultimately resulted in electrons
simulating an orbit but without a
nucleus
and they said it simulated the elemental
properties of this similar atomic weight
or whatever
i don't know what this book was maybe
none of that's true but i was reading
this book on physics i got it at a
bookstore once and i i thought about
that and i'm like i kind of feel that's
what the left is in a similar sense it
is all of the people orbiting around
nothing
it is it is similar to a religious
belief where people have
a core belief system based on something
and they're you know orbiting around it
and then you have the left which has no
no core no nucleus and it's simulating
some kind of you know religious system
that's look the giveaway is men give
birth
i mean
that people now believe
not only believe it but believe that if
you deny it
you are anti-science
and and you are a hater but yeah i i
don't i don't know if people actually
believe that um i understand there are
people who espouse it
but you we mentioned this the other day
if you take a look at joe biden's real
clear politics approval rating his
aggregate it's 30 right now today it's
38.7 it is very low and you'd think that
if two-thirds of the country outright
was like we do not like joe biden
then mainstream comics would be like
well that's the market right
more money is to be made advertising to
the majority group so let's go with it
biden sucks instead they're still on
board with joe biden where are the
regular people if the polls are showing
this to come out and say
no i don't like the guy they don't speak
up people refuse to speak up so there
are a lot of people who will be like oh
yeah i agree with that and then in
private be like i really don't but i'm
terrified that's right
and and that's their that's their secret
weapon or it's not so secret
we'll destroy you if you oppose us
we don't have that
uh uh for years on my radio show i said
to people i can't stand ben and jerry i
think they're moral idiots but i eat
their ice cream because in america you
don't buy products based on whether or
not you agree with the makers of the
product now you do that well that
there's no choice
because but they started and who started
matters
they they started destroying uh
when chick-fil-a's owner simply said i'm
a christian and i and i believe that
marriage is between a man and a woman
the attempt to destroy
uh a chick-fil-a by the way chick-fil-a
has done a 180 degree change as it
happens but but that's a separate issue
but what do you what do you mean the
change they've they've them support yeah
sorry the support for uh blm
yeah chick-fil-a's gone gone woke
basically
not as severely as perhaps nike but uh i
gotta open my own chicken sandwich shop
now so i was talking about making a
non-woke coffee shop and it's like we we
make coffee we don't talk politics end
of story now i gotta do a chicken shop
beef liver beef liver shop it's going to
change everything
just trust me on this people are going
to understand
beef they're going to understand it in
the chat room i got a question for you
guys and i don't want to change the
topic but i miss the last couple minutes
and if you're ready for a new topic i've
been thinking about free will and
determinism a lot lately right you're
familiar with the concept free will you
have the ability to choose your
surroundings i think you do but it
requires glucose like it drains your
your energy system so we need food we
can't do free will without food so we're
determined we're bound
so if we're bound and determined that we
have to have food what even idea of free
will do we even think we have like is it
even a real thing we're just well i i i
could answer that in in a way that you
may not have addressed
if there is no god there is no free will
that that's an irony if there is no god
we are just physical beings therefore
everything we do
is determined by the physical by neurons
firing in our brain period end of issue
we we are sophisticated robots if there
is no god if there's a god there is i'll
use me there's a dentist that is not
just physical there is a dentist that
actually controls my brain it's it's
called the mind i have a soul i'm not
just physical if there is no god you are
just a robot let's let's let's go deep
on this one we talked about the google a
i bought the other day did you hear the
story
google engineer said i was talking to a
chatbot and i said are you alive and it
said yes and you went
and a lot of people make fun of this you
know elon musk was making fun of it
because
the way chat bots work you know they're
not necessarily not really ai's is that
they read the internet and they
determine what words come after other
words probabilistically
so if you say
hi how are you
the chatbot just looks at every
conversation and reads the internet and
says
99.9 percent of the time after someone
says hi how are you the response is fine
99.9 of the time the response the word
after fine is thank followed by you
it's pure probability if you don't
believe that there is something beyond
this existence if there's something
greater and you are just a wet robot as
many people have as i've been told then
i say all of your actions are simply
dominoes falling over for which you have
no control over you are a system of
probabilities you have no free will if
as you described it you are something
else's soul piloting your body then you
are directly influencing the system and
moving the dominoes out of the way and
rearranging them
another way to phrase it other
conversations that we like to go deep on
is dmt trips in which talking with
michael malus and alex jones have been
absolutely fascinating on the subject
and there is an idea that
you're familiar with dmt i'd imagine no
uh dimethyltryptamine i think that's
right
so ian please when when you take it they
call it blasting off and people say they
experience this um this like shared
reality space where i've talked to
people who uh prominent individuals i'll
leave their names out of it who say that
you know these two personalities
took dmt and then were tripping
but were in the same place and they were
able to communicate with each other and
experience the same thing many people
have have claimed this as well
there's an idea
that when you blast off there are beings
that effectively use our bodies as
puppets or something to that effect that
people have experienced and i find it
fascinating because i'm like it sounds
like you're describing some kind of a
soul or some kind of you know extension
of us outside of our bodies and we are
effectively being controlled over that
extension is when you take dmt you blast
off and then can see through the veil
and see what's really going on
the fascinating thing about this is that
it's similarly described by people
of
religious backgrounds for generations
for millennia and then the best part
about this too is to tie it back
together with modern sensibilities
you're familiar with symbolism i wonder
if you explain it i might be i know what
simulate is simulation theory yeah uh
humans are actually in a civil uh
simulation created by a more advanced
species oh okay yeah i absolutely love
this concept because you have people
like elon musk and these other these
tech bros who are like if it is possible
that we can create a simulation then it
is probable that a more advanced and
powerful civilization created the
universe that we are in and i'm like
that sounds like what i learned in first
grade of religious school when i was
going to catholic school that a being of
greater power
crafted the universe for which we exist
in for some purpose simulation theory is
like level one of what religion has been
talking about for thousands of years i
think it's just described in a way that
doesn't offend people's you know
delicate modern sensibilities
the the
ultimate
issue as you're pointing out we're all
pointing out really as much as people
are annoyed
to acknowledge it is the god issue yeah
people
really don't want to believe something
is higher than they are
and and they will do
anything they they will sooner believe
that life on earth was created by
extraterrestrials
than by a god well i i kind of want to
pull back a little bit find out i kind
of disagree because people who aren't
you know per se religious do have
religious idols uh people like dr fauci
uh andrew cuomo
they have they have candles there's no
they sing higher than fouchy yeah they
they sing songs about them they they
they preach everything they say that was
our point and we all met there are
secular they're secular substitutes
douglas murray have you had him on no i
don't think so
let me let me do a shout out for douglas
murray
let me do a shout out by the way for
julie hartman she's 22 you look her up
on the internet and i do a weekly
podcast with her i've never done a
podcast with any other person in 40
years she's 22 and i deal with her you
you you will go nuts for her she just uh
i hate to say this because it's so
irrelevant but some people might find it
relevant she just graduated harvard and
by the way it's a very touching story at
the graduation 36 000 people are there
and uh the the uh the new zealand prime
minister who's as woke as it gets on
planet earth she's the one who i play on
my radio show regularly saying if you
haven't heard it from the government it
isn't true
there's no no compunction about saying
that anyway she spoke about how they
have all these laws uh for
uh unlimited abortion in new zealand and
35
999 people stood up except for julie
just for the record
so so yeah i want to i want to bring up
this idea i was talking to someone who
said they were atheist and i feel like
at the very least atheism um
i i can't i can't understand right you
know i grew up catholic briefly then i
had a period was like i'm an atheist i
don't believe any of that and then i
realized oh actually i can't assert that
i don't have evidence to assert the lack
of i can certainly be agnostic now i
i've you know i more believe in god i do
believe in god
but i was talking with someone and i
said you you just mentioned there are
people who can't imagine there's
something higher than they're more
powerful than them and to me that's a
logical impossibility that there isn't
it you know very simply but if you
believe the universe is as vast and as
explosive as it is then you believe that
humans are but simple wet robots that
exist within it certainly there is a
greater degree of sophistication in a
wet robot than us
i think like humans humans are not the
end-all-be-all of physical capability in
terms of particles coming together and
interacting with each other if they're
if humans exist if the universe is as
large you think it as we think it is
certainly there is a higher power than
us well i think the misnomer is that
it's higher it's it's it's happening in
in synchronicity with us on another
plane of perception so like as atoms are
also we're also atoms we're also
subatomic spinners we're also just a dot
out in the galaxy if you're far enough
away looking at us but if you go small
enough and you start to see the vortex
of the vacuum and like i'm studying
these things called plasmin
it's things in the center of clouds of
plasma and when light refracts off of it
it seems to move with some sort of if
not intelligence coherence and i don't
know why it's
why it's doing that like if the
information is being given to plasma
from light and then it's transmitting
into matter
i don't i've never seen the evidence
that it's
intelligent a little too specific it's
okay so you look like what you're
brought up the cosmic microwave
background radiation are you familiar
with it they located with a radio
telescope and it looks like it's arcing
through planetoids and giving it life
maybe giving things life but then you
look at plasma fields and you can see
light
interacting with plasma what's what's
your point though that i think that's i
mean i think that's pretty plainly god i
mean it's the point like
right right there's a greater phenomenon
that's affecting things oh my gosh my
view is
uh i'll put it this way
humans uh an ant
does an ant know what a highway is i saw
this i listened to a talk by some guy i
can't remember where this lecture was he
says does an ant know what a
superhighway is of course not even
though it's built its ant hill right
next to it it's entirely possible that
aliens have built a superhighway right
above us in outer space and we can't
perceive of it or even if we do we don't
understand what it is so we just don't
think about it
that being said i'm like
the idea is that humans and ants evolved
or or are on the same planet and have
very a lot of similarities in their dna
but more importantly a dog humans and
dogs are mammals dogs can actually
communicate with humans on a rudimentary
level and a dog doesn't know what a
superhighway is how it functions or why
it was put there it just knows it's
there
so it's fascinating that we can be so
closely related to a chimpanzee and the
chimpanzee with our dna 99 similar will
not understand the concept of a car or a
highway at all that is the reason it is
so important
like back to the the most brilliant book
ever written the bible we're cr we and
not animals are created in god's image
so even if we had 99.9 of the same dna
that difference is all the difference
you need it means we have moral free
will it means we have the intelligence
that we have it means we can create
symphonies
but i i believe this shows that
it just means there is a likelihood a
greater likelihood of beings well beyond
us beyond our comprehension or
understanding if uh the universe is it i
mean i look at it this way if we only
recently learned that uh the visible
universe
or or perceivable reality is less than
one millionth of reality because you
know uh the chart the electromagnetic
spectrum was discovered what like early
1900s under 1800s or whatever
we only just discovered that i can only
imagine that there's probably a whole
lot more
maybe maybe millions of times more
aspects of reality we have not yet
discovered we cannot perceive directly
the electromagnetic spectrum but we can
create tools that allow us to
effectively see in the dark
are there tools we have not yet created
that would allow us to see in another
form of the dark we haven't yet
discovered there could be uh you know to
throw to star trek subspace you know
some some other elementary aspect of the
universe we can't perceive yet i believe
that's extremely likely because
i think humans
aren't
masters of the universe
i suppose if you are one of these people
who doesn't believe in a god or a higher
power
it may be because you think humans are
the highest power and you can't perceive
of anything beyond them like you were
saying
well i i i to be honest i'm not troubled
by these issues i am troubled by how how
do we uh minimize murder rape torture
i i i have a moral preoccupation with
the universe how can people be become
better they've done a pretty rotten job
in history i just debated somebody in la
two weeks ago who said uh
amazing to me said to me it was a rabbi
who said uh peop human beings are
innately good uh an idea i consider to
be as preposterous as men give birth
and uh
those are the things that trouble me i
can't know about extraterrestrials now
so in the limited time i have on this on
this the plane of this universe i'd like
to minimize evil
that's my preoccupation the left
maximizes evil and and that's why i
fight the left every day i can they they
what they have done
as i said 99
except for hitler which was which was
let's say 10 10 i don't know uh 10 15
million six million jews and millions of
others uh but overwhelmingly the the
genocides of the 20th century were all
communist
so uh that people don't fear the left
shows a they are utterly ignorant of
history and b that they they are uh
morally challenged uh uh almost beyond
redemption i i think
you know if we cut it down to a
rudimentary level going back to what i
was talking about with the politically
discerning and the uninitiated
i i asked you how do you explain these
concept to people who don't have the
mental capacity for it got to make
appeal to their emotions well then you
end up with i'll just say unnamed
powerful elites who take the approach
that the ends justify the means they use
their wealth and power and their
intelligence to manipulate stupid people
into following them and doing what they
want then they accuse us of doing just
that
you know
i look at uh brian stelter he goes on
cnn and says don't watch fox news don't
watch him come to us you got who was it
was it jake tapper who was like you
can't read the wikileaks emails was that
tapper or was that uh was that cuomo
that was tapper right
i have to double check one of them check
really quickly one of the guys cnn said
you you can't read the emails from me
because we're journalists who are
allowed anybody who tells you do not
seek out the information for yourself in
my opinion like probably lying to you i
figured out yet over here on what they
call the right we're constantly like
please fact check us and look this up
for yourself to make sure it's true and
correct because we're trying our best
the way to get through to the people
that aren't thinking critically is you
got to make god exciting
oh well again i think it's a badass dude
what's more exciting than having meaning
in life that's pretty exciting you know
what's exciting to raise another subject
but one utterly related to the god issue
and everything else it's exciting to
make a family it's not exciting to stay
single it was single is not as exciting
as marriage i've been both
and and uh i know that a lot of single
people think you can't think of anything
more boring than being married
they don't understand that
making a family raising kids having a
partner through life that's damn damn
exciting compared to gee where will i
have dinner tonight i'm single i can
decide i don't have to bounce that off
somebody else but you know what i think
happens for a lot of people is
for one they don't understand the value
they don't understand their roots or the
history or the cultural significance and
we've become uh
gluttonous in a sense
good times make weak men as it were uh
what i was going to say is if there's
one thing that is a wake-up call to
anyone who is single that you need to
have a family it's going to the hospital
being a single adult male and having an
issue with go to the hospital and you're
lying in that bed all by yourself
and you're like oh this is this is very
bad like
you're in trouble that's a tough one
because if you haven't been married you
don't know how great it is i think right
because this society for the first time
in its history has not told every young
person get married they tell them get a
career
and then so all these career women call
my show that's that's the great
advantage of having a talk show i talk
to
i talk with people not just two people i
talked with them in half of 40 years and
i should make a collection of of the
calls from women 50
who have phds and who and and who make
easily well into six figures but they
have no husband and they have no
children and uh they they they believe
they were sold a terrible bill of goods
and they were so let's talk about this
we you know we've had um various dating
experts and personalities talk about
this issue i'm curious on what the
experience is what do you commonly hear
from women who have careers over
families
look the i i i have to be intellectually
honest tell you these are the ones
calling my show they may well call a
left-wing show and say oh i am so
thrilled i never had a husband and
children because i can't tell you how
much i enjoy being the ceo of of of this
uh
computer software company that that may
well be i can't imagine such a person by
the way i can't imagine it even in a man
and men are more driven in generally
speaking in in the in the macro arena
just the way male nature is for better
or for worse uh but uh uh the uh the
according to
even the new york times the it is the
highest rate of depression among young
women in american history we have never
had what we have had now it is
completely a function of of of the
feminist lie
that a woman without a man is like a
fish without a bicycle oh you don't need
men you need a career that will really
make your life and it was a function of
the lockdowns what i called in april
2020 people can see it on the internet i
was universally mocked for it the
greatest mistake in history
on a worldwide uh basis the lockdowns
which they turned out to be uh uh yet uh
yet people bought it uh for for uh
reasons because once they hear
experts say
experts say to the secular is what thus
saith the lord is to the religious do
you think that maybe uh maybe birth
control is playing a role in in this
so um you know it's hormonal mass
medication of young women
and obviously the left's attitude is
it's good it's important that way women
can can date and and be promiscuous
enough to worry about having a baby and
they can maintain their career but i'm
also wondering if if it uh perhaps
alters the the perception one thing
we've that i've read is that uh women
often get advised to get off birth
control before marrying their partner
their significant other because
it alters their perception and many
women will find after getting off birth
control their their man smells bad and
they say that if that's true don't marry
them because something's not right but
being on birth control clouds that that
perception
if that's the case i'm wondering if this
is also clouding other issues and
perhaps
if a woman is on birth control maybe
it's an issue of you know when she comes
off with control birth control and she's
older and that hormone is removed from
the body maybe her perception changes or
something to that effect i never heard
that uh
have you heard that lydia sorry
about the smell thing i have heard that
about the smell thing and i've heard
that if you smell your partner and they
don't it's very subconscious and
sometimes you don't even notice it until
after you're not on birth control
anymore now i don't exactly have
anything that i ca i personally can say
about this because i lost my sense of
smell to covet in november it's been
gone since november so it's been gone
for a really long wow and i'm getting to
the point where i'm worried that when i
have my first child i won't be able to
smell them which is horrifying but when
you bring up the sense of smell with
women it's like they don't even realize
it's something that they're missing so
it's very subconscious and i think it's
something that should definitely it has
a lot to do with pheromones and it has a
lot to do to see if they're compatible
with each other biologically um and this
is why you know a lot of people also put
on a lot of heavy metals and deodorants
right in their armpits right into one of
their the major flows of blood in their
entire body that also has a lot of
negative health consequences there's
been horror stories after horror stories
when it comes to birth control in women
um and and business insider had a very
interesting article in 2015 that was
titled women now control more than half
of us personal wealth which will only
increase in years to come and i think uh
i don't know if you could pinpoint it to
one particular thing but we are seeing
the destruction of the family unit we
are seeing a depopulation plan that has
been rolled out that is implemented and
we're seeing the larger consequences of
this where elon musk just tweeted even a
couple hours ago about u.s birth rates
being below minimal sustainable levels
for over 50 years now the fertility
rates have been dropping testosterone
rates have been dropping right right
a lot of children
religious catholics religious jews
religious protestants and religious
mormons well i'll i'll tell you i know
everybody who listens to this shows
they've heard me say it
there was a study in the early 2000s
that found conservatives were having
about 2.01 kids per family and liberals
were having like 1.73
the logic is simple 20 years later we
see in pew research gen z is slightly
more conservative than millennial but
they're very very similar well it makes
sense it's not that gen z were red
pilled it's that conservatives had more
kids so if you get 100 conservatives 100
liberals and the liberals only have 70
kids out of the 100 100 parents and the
conservatives have 100 kids you take
that 100 conservative kids and 70
liberal kids put them together and pull
the 170 and you're like wow it's mostly
conservative i wonder why simply put
there was a i read a story that said the
future is muslim
because muslims have even more kids than
christian conservatives do and they said
it's simple math that if liberals are
are going to be aborting their children
and not and just not trying to have kids
in the first place more likely for the
women to have careers conservatives are
more likely to have kids but devout
religious fundamentalist muslim are
having substantially more kids then the
future will skew in the direction of
that faith and a lot of the the people
who don't have a religion don't believe
in in in a higher power usually are more
susceptible to propaganda on the
television and there's been a lot of
subliminal propaganda saying don't have
children this is especially true in
europe where there's major
advertisements saying you could be more
free you could enjoy life more if you
don't have your children and don't have
your children because it's bad for the
environment
that's it you're morally obligated
exactly
for the
carbon emissions problem i think it's
funny that that there's that meme that
says you are the carbon they're trying
to reduce yeah that's a misnomer about
carbon when they literally write
articles saying that it's like there's
this belief that we have too much and
that that's that but we're going to
start pulling carbon out of the air
there's technology where you can deposit
carbon dioxide onto palladium and create
graphene out of it which is just a
monoatomic layer of carbon and then we
can reuse the graphene as a building
material so we'll start harvesting the
carbon dioxide and competing with trees
and then we're going to need more carbon
dioxide they they will
i am convinced that the greens
if we had perfect technology to remove
carbon dioxide they would still push
uh for uh for uh
sun uh
solar panels and uh
and uh windmills they they but not
nuclear power that's that's the proof
right nuclear power is the proof
there is a romantic fixation on
bringing us back to the 17th century or
18th century
nuclear power is powers 60 of france's
electricity it is safe
it is clean if if indeed carbon is dirty
it is clean and yet they are opposed to
nuclear power so if that i've read about
that and you would think that they would
be thrilled to know that but they are no
more thrilled about removing carbon
dioxide than they are about nuclear
power they want us to use solar panels
and wind power germany got rid of all of
their their nuclear power plants right
because well i have a theory which is
not meant to be bigoted
and there are certainly exceptions but
my theory is germany is always wrong no
when angela merkel did that
she just fed my belief germany is always
wrong well they were they were really
hoping to be dependent upon russian gas
and oil so isn't that beautiful if i
could ask you because you said you
traveled in a lot of eastern european
countries uh if you don't mind me
transitioning here what do you think of
what's happening in ukraine right now
what's your perspective from everything
since there's a mainstream media
establishment push from one perspective
but it's a very complicated situation
so i don't think it's as complicated as
a lot of my my
fellow uh conservatives think it is
uh russia did something evil in invading
ukraine
uh you can you can think things through
to the end was is the ukrainian
government corrupt okay if we don't
defend
the the uh independence of a country
because the government is corrupt we
will never defend any country
uh government is corrupt almost by
definition because power corrupts and
absolute power corrupts absolutely as
was said by lord acton in the 19th
century tends to corrupt absolutely oh
is that we said tens i thought i thought
corrupts all right either way i i take a
look by i am curious i want to i want to
quote it correctly either way it's
accurate uh so uh
look uh
this this is this what we should do is a
separate question from the moral one
remember i think in moral terms the
invasion of ukraine
the obliteration of its independence or
the attempt to do so is evil if that's
not evil then then then why was why why
was germany's invasion of poland evil
so uh lord acton said power tends to
corrupt and absolute power corrupts
absolutely so i got the second part
right and the first part wrong because i
dropped tens from the first part and i
think i got i was assuming the tens was
on the last part right so yeah we both
got one part wrong so so what do you
think about the the 40 billion and now
today
one billion that's going to ukraine uh
as of right so that's a that's a very
fair question
uh
the the original sin about the 40
billion
is that we printed a trillions of
dollars of dollars uh by because of the
democrats
and and that is what has created the
uh not the only thing that has created
the terrible inflation
and the other is that we are now giving
not from our surplus weapon weaponry but
from our the heart of our weaponry
because the democrats have over the
course of decades said we don't need so
many weapons as we have uh but if
america is not the strongest country on
earth uh cruelty will dominate the earth
that's just the fact
of life and conservatives should be the
first to say that
but what does that does what does that
mean i mean we're looking at a
multipolar world with china
now coming to compete
my belief is that china is looking and
saying whoa
if if sweden and
and finland want now to join nato
maybe it's a maybe the backlash against
putin
may have us think rethink our desire to
invade taiwan i don't think that china
is more likely to invade taiwan
given the reaction of the western world
to russia i think they're less likely to
do so i thought the same thing
really yeah yeah most people uh think
differently i think they think uh this
is emboldening china i don't think it's
emboldening china you see the way russia
got annihilated financially when it
happened yes that's right exactly
well if you look at the markets now it's
far more complicated but earlier we
talked about how do we prevent the loss
of life how can we do that especially in
ukraine when i i think it's it's very
essential and very clear that the united
states is just giving them enough
weapons to prolong this war they gave
them specific hardware that was missing
uh equipment on it that would have been
a game changer for the ukrainians but
but they're giving equipment just enough
to prolong the conflict but not have a
decisive victory
emanuel macron the president of france
came to this larger kind of geopolitical
conundrum and he said that there has to
be some kind of a peace deal there has
to be some kind of negotiation um and
he's he's even suggesting some kind of
way to de-escalate this entire situation
i would love to see is is your
perspective do you need to escalate or
is your perspective you should
obliterate
no i would love to de-escalate uh but uh
look
if you really want a an original sin or
at least a beginning sin
uh uh
in the direction of what you're saying
it is it is this president
which i say with difficulty i admit this
president saying uh that uh putin has to
go
you have put putin in the place of i
have no choice but to win
but
but for the new york times and and the
entire
elite of this country
there is no
sin biden can commit
because any democrat is better than any
republican and by the way i believe
virtually any republican is better than
any democrat so i i just want to make
that clear i think the democrats are
ruining america they think republicans
are ruining america that's why we we may
have a civil war that is correct that
was your original point of the of the of
our dialogue here but but his saying
putin has to go that he's a war criminal
then putin is going to say i'm crazy for
for
for for doing anything but going whole
hog into into ukraine they they've given
the man no way out not they biden and
the democrats
yeah i think the whole situation is
extremely dangerous i i it is extremely
dangerous striving towards you know
negotiations de-escalation yeah but he
does he doesn't want to negotiate i
agree with you why would you so why
would you say i agree since i agree with
you what is the modus operandi that we
would get him to negotiate
say we'll give you eastern ukraine
this is that's what biden actually
proposed uh the president of the united
states actually proposed doing that uh
is that a solution no i don't claim to
know any any answers here but i think uh
aggravating the situation is definitely
not not the right approach here
aggravating and defending are identical
uh yeah it depends you always aggravate
a situation when you arm the victim well
if we're going to be doing something
here we we should do it decisively not
to prolong a proxy conflict well i don't
know well um
and you know there's been specific
military munitions especially when it
comes to the howitzers that are missing
key gps components that would change the
game but the united states is not giving
them that so so that to me i think this
is again a very complex issue i don't
claim to know the answers here i don't
claim to know the solutions as a polish
person we always have a lot of distrust
against the soviets and the russians for
good and obviously so because of the
history and the bloodshed and the life
loss that was committed there you know
and this is a conundrum that that is
is is very well when i went to poland uh
during the cold war because that again
that was my field so i speak russian and
i spoke i go to you know poland
czechoslovakia bulgaria east germany
romania so i would go there and because
i spoke russian
uh i got along because they had to learn
russian right they had no choice so i
would ask let's say a poll so i would go
yamare kanyez i'm an american governing
porous do you speak russian and every
single one gave the same answer da
yes but i don't want to
it sounds like there might be people
that want a limited war right now like
another vietnam in ukraine even
kissinger came out and was like that's a
bad idea by the way he's like the
architect of limited war uh because it's
better than a total war but he's like
this is not the time or the place to do
a limited war
i don't know why maybe because
corporations are the arms manufacturers
right now and they don't care about any
government well i i not to deviate i
suppose but dennis why do you think
ukraine's fallen out of the news cycle
people get bored when there there is
nothing new to report and and they are
understandably more preoccupied with
their own lives whether whether whether
right or wrong
and they they are watching america
crumble
uh financially economically morally
and uh that that's the reason why what
is there to report i mean look
v vietnam i mean i'm old enough to
remember the vietnam war and
there was a point where people tuned out
of the vietnam war reports they they
were they were still made and of course
that was much more directly involved
because americans were dying americans
are not dying in ukraine which is
another factor americans are not dying
in ukraine
so it it's it's understandable uh
and
and that's that
i want to show you guys this image this
is from james lindsey but this is
something that we've actually talked
about in the show this is a poll showing
five different regions of the united
states and their propensity towards uh
seceding from the union by region based
on political party you can see the
southern states which is uh
you know texas florida virginia et
cetera
shows uh 66 percent i believe that's a
little small 66 percent of republicans
favor secession
in the heartland as it's described 43
of independent voters favor succession
in the mountain region the uh plurality
is 43 percent of republicans
in the pacific region i believe it's 47
percent of democrats favor secession in
the northeast it's split fairly evenly
39 democrat 35 independent and then a
smaller portion of republicans so here's
what i did when i saw this story i took
each region
their total population and the
percentages based on political
affiliation of population then i
normalized it for the entire country
using this data to find
37.2 percent of people in this country
favor their particular region breaking
off to form its own country
more than one-third
of people in this country want their
region to secede
that is an extreme extrapolation i don't
know if i would be comfortable saying
talking about a third of the country
because how many people were pulled here
six thousand like we we i if you ask
these people how many of you want world
peace you'd get 98 percent of the people
in the northeast want world peace they
don't know what it means they don't know
what succession means
that doesn't refute what i'm saying just
because someone doesn't know what it
means to destroy things doesn't mean
they're not going to advocate for it but
to say that 6 000 people want it so
therefore a third of the united states
extrapolates is a misnomer i think is a
misconception i just think uh you don't
understand how polling is done that's
how polling is done they think it's a
small segment and then they extrapolate
it to the whole is it and it's not right
right right so when you're looking at
various sample sizes typically there's a
scientifically weighted poles
that are that have a margin of error
included in it and to the best of our
understanding this is the sentiment oh
the point i was making is i think they
don't know what that means to secede
they would they want to pee everyone
wants a nice peaceful divorce where
everyone gets a smile going look at
where harper's fairy is dude it's like
between three like do you know what to
say the bloodshed that went on in the
heart okay so you're both right and i'm
not trying to be a nice guy here uh that
they don't really understand it's not
feasible is what you're saying it's it's
infinitely complex it's not like the
south seceding that's one whole region
and it leaves whereas you know what are
you going to do is
to give harper's ferry the example you
gave but but i think you're right that
that
that percentage of americans do want to
leave the other part of america i live
in california and if la san francisco uh
decided to uh
make their own state with all their
wealth and everything else they had i
would be a very happy man so i i am in
that little group i know it can't happen
but if you were to pull me
and ask me would you like san francisco
and la uh to secede from california and
make their own very wealthy state i
would say i would love to and live in
the other part it can happen
so
you know they didn't think the first
civil war could happen i thought it was
impossible
people were having picnics on the hill
overlooking fort sumter thinking nothing
was going to happen and it was all
nothing in fact even after the battle i
i'm not sure if it was uh lee
said i don't even know if this battle
matters sure enough it was the battle
that kicked off the civil war
abraham lincoln wasn't even president
when the first i believe seven states
seceded then he comes in and he says i
do not recognize secession the southern
state said too late we seceded before
you even president
then he comes in and says we're taking
these military bases fighting breaks out
a whole bunch of other states are like
you've lost the plot attacking states we
are out as well
nobody believed a state could do it
until it until it happened so i take a
look at polls like this and i take a
look at numerous
advancements towards seceding from at
least
counties or cities we've got oregon a
bunch of these districts in the in the
east of oregon want to secede from the
state to join the greater state of
jefferson or north carolina wants a seed
to join the state of jefferson to create
a new state
the sentiment is there and all that it
takes for the sentiment to become
reality is a lack of confidence in the
system in the first civil war the issue
was the nor one of the issues was the
north was not following federal law
particularly the fugitive slave act
the south said if we've packed
and we all agree congress that's the law
you have to follow it and these states
do not follow it and the federal
government doesn't enforce it then there
clearly is no pact we're out because
it's you know in their perspective it
was just well they already decided that
the the federal government wasn't
standing so we have no point in being a
part of this union
it's entirely possible that we see the
same thing this time around that it may
seem unthinkable until
it just happens gradually then suddenly
i'm not saying that it can't shatter
because the u.s could fall apart and
shatter but it wouldn't look like that
it wouldn't be like six nice and cut
neatly parts it'd be like do you want to
board your windows up and hope that the
air force doesn't strike tonight kind of
thing and no one wants that but but
these people don't get that
and i know that because we've had people
say peaceful divorce over and over again
and what i tell them you know luke
talked about peaceful divorce uh early
on michael malus has and i say that's
what the first civil war was for the
first few months it was a bunch of
states saying we hereby decree have a
nice day and that was it
until the issue of weapons came up and
then abraham lincoln the union said
those military bases are ours and we
want them and the southern states were
like well you're no longer welcome here
and then they fought and that led to a
greater fight now on the north side you
had a whole bunch of people who were
ideologically driven who absolutely were
like now is the time to shut down
slavery and i think that was correct so
i but you know i bring this up just to
say when two
different groups feel the law is not
being upheld and that the social
contract has already shattered it's not
an issue of them declaring secession
it's an issue of them saying you already
seceded let me give you if i may a micro
example
i advocate almost every day on my radio
show
that in in the great majority of
instances parents should take their kids
out of school and homeschool them or
find one of the rare decent schools for
their kids a school that will not rob
their children of sexual innocence at
the age of five a school that will not
teach them the lie that america was
founded in 1619 and other terrible lies
and calamies about america
so uh that that is succession i'm asking
parents to secede from the public school
system and and the private school system
so uh yeah i think if you do it we we
we have
an an irreparable divide i i say this
with great sadness but we always have
religion
all these different fractured cultures
and religions that was the independence
yeah it's not been this big um it's
definitely expensive oh this is new this
is new just like the war on free speech
that to me that's all you need to know
that uh uh 45
of college students
uh say that they are
for free speech but not for a free
speech for hate speech that's the end of
free speech that you keep saying about
not thinking clearly that's a perfect
example
the whole point of free speech is that
it allows speech you think is hate
speech
otherwise you wouldn't need the kind of
exactly what is there free speech for
love speech are you an idiot and yes
they are they're idiots
and they were rendered idiots because
they at 10 they understood the concept
of free speech for any speech but if
they went to college they don't here's
my proposal scenario which i'm not
saying is probable i'm just saying
potential or or you know maybe not even
maybe it's a very very micro possibility
i'm just saying here's something i see
as
a possible path toward civil war
they keep
dancing around roe v wade rowan casey
getting overturned we had last night
scuttlebutt coming out of the dc uh you
know staffers and journalists saying
that the decision was coming today and
then it didn't now they're like maybe
next week you know we'll see and it
seems to me that they're really just
trying to shock everyone and then pull
it back to try and desensitize them but
anyway digress here's my potential
scenario
row and casey are overturned abortion
goes back to the states instantly uh was
it a dozen states have trigger laws
abortion becomes illegal overnight blue
states double down and say abortion to
the point of birth which we already see
in colorado and was attempted in
virginia there are i think a couple
other states that have completely
unrestricted abortion which means a baby
at nine months just gestation which
could survive on its own is killed and
removed from the woman
i then think we're going to look at a
red wave in november and we've already
had uh you know jamal bowman say that if
oh you know civil war is at stake if if
we don't win this one
and there are people who are saying that
the country can't exist at the midterms
it's over it's civil war
so let's say republicans get in you know
talking to uh actually let me ask you
this dennis you're you're pro-life
yeah i i i believe in compromising for
the sake of the greater good so that if
if if we could have it
the second two thirds of the of
pregnancy if we could make exceptions in
rape and abortion rape and rape and
incest fully understanding i believe
that it is a human life would you
support a nationwide ban on elective
abortion
a nationwide ban on elective abortion
meaning no no reason given uh i i know i
fully understand that
throughout the pregnancy
yeah in other words even from conception
uh and even including rape and incest i
would not support that law because the
greater good for the country would would
i think militate against it i don't know
about i think in the issue of rape and
incest but uh
that would be well so that it wouldn't
be across the board well so i think i i
think oklahoma
uh
was it oklahoma or it may have been
texas i'm not sure oklahoma they say no
elective abortions rape incest health of
the mother and the baby are reasons for
abortion right
would you agree with that what
oklahoma's doing or no you think there's
got to be i think it should be decided
on not a national level i think it
should be decided on a state level so
my i i think you know that's what people
pushed back on me when i presented this
scenario a lot of republicans said no no
because we believe in the state level so
my my potential is you know at talking
with sheamus for instance who's a
catholic conservative i said would you
support a nationwide ban on abortions
absolutely
and so let's just say hypothetically the
chances are very very slim republicans
decide we are going to push for a
nationwide ban on elective abortion or
at the very least they say something
like no abortion after 12 weeks we're
going to use the european standard
the left loses it and says absolutely
not
you then end up with it passing i'll put
it this way
the house and senate are republican they
pass the bill biden vetoes it they do
not have a veto proof majority or they
can't get past a filibuster come 2024
donald trump says the first thing i'll
do when elected is sign the bill and
then he gets he gets elected day one he
signs the bill sends it out boom
nationwide no abortion after 12 weeks
the left says we don't care we're going
to do it anyway blue states begin
carrying on as if it's not uh
you know not an issue
the the issue i see there then is it
becomes very similar to the issue of
slavery
one state saying we deny personhood
everyone else saying we grant personhood
in this instance you have conservatives
who believe that life begins a
conception and the fetus is a person
deserving of rights and you have the
left that says they're not and they
don't
so i i suppose what i see there is a
very similar situation which could
ignite a civil war blue state saying we
will not follow federal law red state's
saying if you're not following the law
then how do we have a union blue state
saying we're going to do this anyway and
then red states saying or at least the
federal level we're going to stop you
from breaking the law
i suppose where it really gets dark is
in um i think it may have been louisiana
they attempted to codify abortion as
homicide was it was it louisiana
one of these states
if that were ironically it is homicide
well but unless the the woman wants to
kill it which is part of the the moral
inconsistency of the pro-choice
community
it is homicide so let me entertain this
legal conundrum
if
there was a a man
a white man who kidnapped a black man
and had him in chains and was demanding
he worked for him and be a slave or
something
you try to intervene and say release
this man i'm gonna save him i'm
intervening if that crazed guy
attacks you
and you in defense of this other man
kill him you're acting in the defense of
others it's an affirmative defense as it
pertains to the taking of a person's
life
what my concern is
if we do see the codification of
abortion as a homicide as a criminal act
akin to any other murder
then could a person not
defend the life of the child against the
abortion provider well that is the
reason when you asked me do i want a
national law banning all abortions and i
and i had hesitation even though i am
pro-life
is that
i think that the pro-life community as
well needs needs to be
honest in confronting
the fact that we don't see it as
identical to murder i i've never called
it murder i've always called it homicide
i've always called it immoral but i've
never called it murder
and it it becomes murder i would say by
by the third trimester i think it does
become murder i i think there's a
graduated
element of sin or evil uh in the in the
abortion world but i have i asked when i
began radio this question if it's murder
why don't you kill abortion doctors
if next door to you and they don't what
was it was a was a concentration camp
killing jews you would feel morally
obligated to murder the commandant of
the camp you made a comment about the
greater good uh we got to go to super
chats yeah we were welcome
we're way late in the after
sorry sorry man uh but we're eight
minutes late we're gonna go to super
chats smash the like button subscribe to
the channel share the show head over to
timcast.com we've got a lot more
conversation to be have uh to be had
obviously it's getting a little spicy so
we'll move this over to uh the the
website members only show over at
timcast.com but for now we'll try and
get as many super chances super chats
super chances
super chats in
right now
moon phaser says will tim fight in the
civil war oh man i do not want to be
involved in that and neither do you
i have been on the streets of urban
conflict that was gradually actually no
i've been in a i don't know i've been a
revolution before not fun
i mean there's a certain element that's
exciting to it but you do not want to
live that way yeah it is it is scary
stuff war is hell on earth yep
all right
matt nils says tim and dennis i never
thought i'd see you in the same room but
it makes my heart warm dennis i met you
in orlando florida at the holy land
experience a few years ago you said my
beard made me look like smith bros cough
drops
i remember that guy do you know smith
brother's roast trunks no i didn't think
so okay fine is it an older thing yeah i
guess so yeah oh it's worth looking up
on the internet smith brothers cough
drops look at the the little box
smacky frogs i say tim what pillow were
you sleeping on when your back was
injured my pillow or our pillow need to
know for science
i it was some weird foam dense but i
hate foam pillows i hate memory foam
it's awful and it's like my shoulder
back it's like a combination of my
shoulder and back i strained a muscle
really bad so it's you
just taking taking naproxen like create
a leave and it's not good for your
stomach i'm looking at the dude's beard
from smith brothers that's hot
yeah good
all right john harrison says time to see
if ian is enough of a ma mad lad to
start an anti-christianity rant with
prager looking him in the eye
okay i'll take this as an opportunity to
ask you who do you like better jesus or
moses
well i i i'm a believing jew it's it's
unfair to christians for me to answer it
because obviously if i if i thought
jesus had a better message i'd be a
christian
so i i
have great admiration for jesus uh i am
probably the the biggest non-christian
defender of christianity in america i
think i brought more people back to
their christian church than than almost
any christian living
to be honest and i'm proud of that fact
but i'm a believing jew not a believing
christian i should point out i love the
idea of christianity being the anointed
one living like christ but i'm not into
the authoritarian nature of church of
the organization of it
maybe we can talk about that at some
point well yeah there
look religion can't be a democracy you
don't you don't vote on the ten
commandments this is like the old jewish
joke moses comes down
for those who don't know their bible he
came down twice he came down with the
ten commandments the first time he saw
the israelites worshiping the golden
calf and having an orgy and uh he
smashes them comes down the second time
and he announces israelites i have good
news and bad news
i got him down to 10.
the bad news adultery stays
uh if people had to vote on on adultery
they'd have they'd have voted to to get
rid of it
so there has to be an authoritarian
element
god is the ultimate authority whether
the the institution can be authoritarian
i'm not for that that i agree with i am
not for a theocracy if that in in the
sense that a religious
government like an iran can tell you
what to do religiously have you ever all
right from god let's read some more yes
every time i read the bible i hear from
god but i have never directly heard from
god all right we got fox tashicato says
hey tim and crew how is it that the left
woke mob that is pretty small group and
really uh and really on here in the us
has the most power do you think this is
backed by big tech and social media or
something else
so what do you think how does the left
have so much power considering they're
actually a small group of people it's
irrelevant the uh
again this is where unfortunately my
studies and communism worked so the name
for the communists in russia was
bolsheviks bolsheviks means uh majority
mix majority group they were the
minority group but they called
themselves the majority group uh the
nazis were only one third of the of the
vote in in germany in 1932 and they took
over you you don't need and i'm not
saying that the left are nazis i'm just
showing you that that
you don't need to be a majority to take
over a country i thought you made it
interesting you need to be ruthless you
made a good point about um banning free
speech and just the curtailing and i'm
thinking about algorithmic uh shadow
banning where people don't know that
they're being slowed down on the network
like if you were in a room speaking to a
thousand people and you didn't know that
they weren't hearing you and you were
just talking and you thought they were
hearing you that would be unconscionable
for the event that put it on they would
be slandered in the media for doing that
to you but on twitter if they've
de-ranked your account yes they can
decide facebook has done that to prageru
i remember that yeah yeah let's read
this when we got lord blueberry says
they laughed at dennis when he said
leftist claimed men could menstruate
bill maher owes him an apology
as bill has built uh you know what i
it's the last thing on my mind i would
like to go back on his show and i won't
even i won't
look i'm so happy that you gotta give
him a look you gotta be like i'll i'll
give him a look
and i will say i will say tim poole told
me to give you a look and and everybody
everybody will then be happy uh i i um
i expect so little
uh from leftist i expect nothing from
liberals which i think consider bill
maher
there is so lack of so much a lack of
courage among liberals that when there
is a courageous liberal i don't want to
give him a hard time yeah yeah i i hear
you
you know it is what it is i suppose i
just wish bill maher would read the news
the more they know the more they're on
our side i it just that's that's the way
it works
that's the issue for me i mean 51 heads
of of national intelligence agencies in
this country
said that the the hunter biden laptop
was russian disinformation
51.
i don't know of an exception among the
heads of all intelligence in the united
states it's corrupt beyond words this is
new in america i grew up with such a
veneration of this country and its
institutions it's actually in some ways
it's worse for you you who are younger
than me and it's worse for me because i
see what happened when i was a kid
superman was was a truth justice and the
american way now superman is no longer
an american did you know that yeah he
stood in front of the u.n and he
announced i i get i give up my american
citizenship he uh he is no longer truth
justice in the american way it is now
truth justice and the better way he's
not an american anymore superman i grew
up in a country where where you you
visited the graves of the fallen on
memorial day i mean it's i grew up in a
different country these institutions did
it to themselves to be you know i mean
yes it started with the war machine the
the lies manipulation wmds iraq all of
this stuff that disillusion my
generation or at least i can speak for
me and where i grew up how we felt about
it now it's even worse let's read this
here we got daniel maxwell says there's
nothing in the u.s constitution that
says this country is a democracy but
article 4 section 4 does say the u.s
government is obligated to guarantee to
the states a republican form of
government well they wrote replican but
i think they meant republican because
replicants are something else that'd be
great yeah that's from uh it's an
important distinction when we're not
found to be a democracy we're founded to
be a republic that's why there's a
electoral college that's why there's a
senate neither is democratic and it's
and that's why you have this
multicultural democracy among the left
where they keep saying our democracy is
being threatened they're not wrong they
are trying to create a democracy within
a constitutional republic and subvert it
and they're threatened by people who
believe in a constitution you see people
charging the macy's the other day
there's a huge crowd hundreds of people
in the mall talk about democracy in
action that's the mob they want to
coordinate and say no it's about 61
well maybe but that was an example of
people on a facebook group deciding
democratically you tell me
it when macy's comes out and complains
about it i will believe that macy's
cares no macy's what happened at macy's
100 day sale it was a big huge group of
like 100 or plus people just charging to
macy's to rob the place they all run
it's called a raid and they all run and
just grab everything wait a minute
macy's is okay with that
i haven't seen it
have you heard them complain or issues
oh they're probably afraid to complain
well you know they may be called racist
if maybe if in fact i don't know who did
it but if in fact it was largely one
race in this case blacks i think it was
that then then it would be uh it would
be declared racist bots macy's they're
cowards the the the left
the view this is my theory do you know
why uh disney said what it did about we
won't won't say boys and girls anymore
or or all of that stuff this is
protection money yeah it's a racket you
paid the mafia if you're a small
business in in new york you paid the
mafia to is to protect you you pay the
left to protect you
that that that is what it is about these
these corporate leaders are not leftists
they're cowards
all right let's read some more andrew
lance says dennis thank you the rational
bible exodus and your five minute videos
were uniquely responsible for turning my
life around and returning to my catholic
faith four and a half years ago now i'm
happily married with a baby on the way
thank you so much
that makes my day that's awesome
that's right so i just want to say i'm
very bad at self-promotion but nobody
writes a bible commentary to get wealthy
but if
if every one of your know if a tenth of
your listeners read any of my rational
bible volumes
it would enhance their life tremendously
i i'm not here to make you christian or
jewish or anything else
just take god and that book seriously
richard knight says i came home two
years ago excited to tell my christian
mother about this amazing man dennis
prager i had heard on the radio quote oh
my favorite jew she exclaimed god bless
all you and everyone so i always correct
i always correct christians who say i'm
their favorite jew i'm their second
favorite jew that's right jesus jesus
was their first family
all right that's so wild that he was a
jew
have you ever heard of the a religious
jew as i there was a bumper sticker in
greenwich village when i grew up in new
york and it said jesus grew up in a
kosher home
i heard this i don't want to i want to
like the super chats but i heard this
this theory that the roman
like the papacy or these these romans
oligarchs basically created christianity
to disempower the jews
in like i don't know i don't know
i don't think that's true that'd be
freakish yeah
all right there are a lot of bad things
done to jews that were but i i don't
think the romans were in cahoots to do
it
anthony greene says to dennis prager can
a genteel truly convert to judaism kind
of gentile gentile as much as i deeply
respect judaism my opinion is i cannot
elect myself into the chosen people
my god uh
both judaism and christianity hold that
the messiah will come from ruth ruth was
a convert to judaism
the uh
some of the greatest jews who ever lived
with converts to judaism i don't know
why he believes that
but i just want him to know he's more
than welcome to become a jew
all right fluffer boy says i live 15
minutes away from ferguson hands up
don't shoot was a lie also our landfill
is on fire and has illegally buried
nuclear waste from the manhattan project
may you live in interesting times wow is
that true that's crazy
all right
so leo cucumber soleil cucumber lime
says leftist signs is rooted in
humiliation not truth justice reason
logic or morality
i agree
all right
tuben's task manager
says
genesis 18 please read numbers from 50
to 10 not down to one just a minor
correction i just wanted to have it
correct for the future oh was there i
thought you said ten i don't think you
said one
yeah the argument by the way it's this
very important thing for people to
understand i think you'll find this
fascinating
the the name for the jewish people in
the bible is israel israel means and
it's it's in hebrew and it's said so in
the bible the name israel means struggle
with god fight with god
and it began with the first jew abraham
fighting with god over sodom and
gomorrah
so i i
to the great credit of the biggest
atheist group in america about 15 years
ago they invited me to debate their head
about god's existence
i think it's atheist united but i'm not
sure if that was the group anyway the
biggest atheist group to their credit
invited me to debate
and it was a wonderful debate i looked
at the audience all of whom were
atheists and i said
raise your hand if you ever
uh doubt your atheism like you see a
baby born and you go well maybe there
really is a god it's like a miracle not
one hand went up
and then i looked at them and i said
uh whenever i speak to religious groups
and i say raise your hand if you have
ever doubted god every hand goes up
you think we're the ones who don't
struggle and don't doubt and don't
question
you're the ones who don't doubt and
don't struggle and don't question
projection
all right satan's reject says tim i just
listened to will of the people by muse
and i must say is terrible will of the
people by tim cast for life no uh yeah
so i wrote a song
and published it called will of the
people just before the election in 2020
and it's part of a bigger project we're
doing so we're planning on having an
album out probably in august we got a
billboard in times square for the song
now showing the art it's a it's a really
great depiction and uh we're doing a you
know big ad push because we're going to
be releasing the will of the people
album muse also released a very similar
uh concept with a similar color scheme
and theme of people wearing masks and
pulling down statues and i was like wow
that's really a whole lot like lit what
we did and you know but it is what it is
i suppose so if you want check out will
of the people on youtube the song that
we published we've got a couple songs uh
we've got a whole bunch of songs that
are like nearly done and we might have
maybe even 10 songs by august for a full
album we'll see we might just do an ep
but that's coming out and we're going to
do a big ad thing and uh will of the
people by tim cass showing people in
masks pulling down statues is in times
square right now i gotta shout out
chicken city one of the tim cass
channels where the chickens hang out i
heard him singing old macdonald had a
farm the rooster
literally over and over i clipped it
it's on my twitter go listen to it i'm
thinking a farmer
heard a rooster sing it and it was like
i'm making that into a song no
no no no you know they do the eio party
in are you speaking to chickens
watch by twitter it is mind blowing he
did it like eight times he did a couple
days ago too it's one of the new
roosters
by the way you did that well i'm not
joking and i went flat on the last note
he doesn't go flat
all right all right let's read some more
by the way uh so you you have a
billboard up at times square yeah we
have two
so and you're and you're one of the uh
figures on it yes i'm on two of them and
then what do your parents think
uh
i guess they're happy
you're not sure i'm assuming they're
happy i don't know
i was just curious i didn't i you know i
let them do your parents share your
views
uh
i don't know
i think my mom does
yeah i'm just curious i i it's
interesting family my my dad was more
concerned my mom's more liberal growing
up like disagree i think i think my my
dad voted for bush my mom voted for gore
something like that i think they both
voted for ross peroth in the 90s i'm not
entirely sure yeah
uh although
you know i don't know i don't know
i don't know entirely because i don't
talk enough about it okay but um i'm
pretty sure my mom i sent her like hey
look the billboard's up and she was like
great she sends me like a heart emoji or
something i don't know what what did
what what did your mom say luke luke's
up there yeah she was pretty happy she
was like this is cool um
she was she was proud she was like where
did they live
um i don't want to release that for
security reasons uh-huh but they they
don't live in new york i take it maybe
all right
fair enough
you know we we we we also got uh
billboards that just me on it in chicago
and we're looking at doing a bunch of
other uh ad runs
so so i want to put up a prageru
billboard in this case not not about me
but i i you know all these god loves you
god loves you god loves you
uh i i don't think that that's a
critical message uh maybe to some it is
and i honor that
uh i would love to put up some
billboards and see what happens god
judges you
yeah it does
huh it does judge you that's part of the
guilt that people are feeling in the
insanity that they feel when they're not
connected to it because it's telling you
what to do you know what you're supposed
to do
i can't think of one message that would
tick more people off than god judges you
let's read some more here we got vetcan
who says i heard a story about the
origin of polish jokes when they were
forced to manufacture weapons for the
germans they made them faulty on purpose
but played it off so the germans just
thought they were dumb big fan dennis
interesting thank you
let's see
char bizzard says yo tim former
louisiana fry cook here let's open up
tim cast tenders together i got
confidence in my frying skills you won't
be disappointed i don't know if we're
actually going to open a tim filet thing
you know if you do make sure you fry the
french fries and fresh oil and not the
oil that's recycled from the chicken
because that makes some kind of flour
well you know don't use any kind of
vegetable or seed oils at all lard we
used to use lard and poppy natural
butter all right crystal max says hi
dennis my 14 year old son has been
watching the prageru five minute
episodes during his summer break he is
learning so much he is going into high
school and he definitely will have an
advantage
may i just say in that regard i believe
this i would happily be placed on a lie
detector
if you're a child except for stem
science technology engineering math
watch the 500 5-minute videos at prageru
they would learn far far more than at
princeton or any other college in this
country
all right not my regret says i see your
take regarding monotheistic religions
just christianity and the belief in a
singular god being our creator and
determinator of the afterlife but what
is your view on religious religions like
buddhism where there is a belief in the
cycle of reincarnation and karma
i i have great i have great respect for
buddhism there is a buddhist theory that
was told to me by my buddhist professor
in england that changed my life about
all suffering coming from expectations
that are not fulfilled and in my book on
happiness i have a whole chapter on not
having expectations and i give buddhism
credit i i
however
obviously buddhism doesn't have a
transcendental god a transcendent god i
think that's an issue
uh
and and they they
uh they do make peace
with with
with suffering more than i think people
should
all right d stuff says mr prager what is
your view of calvinism and
predestination and all human actions
were predestined by god to occur
including sin and salvation and there's
nothing we can do to change it big fan
of you and tim cast great mashup god
bless i believe in free will and and
that would seem to undermine the belief
that this free will why could god punish
us if he if he ordained what we would do
what do you think about calvinism though
well that's it that's predestination
so i i uh look
a lot of people are better than their
theologies and a lot of people are worse
than their theologies
in this case i would say that calvinists
are better than their theologies
i've been thinking lately that it's both
free will and determinism depending on
your state of mind if you choose to live
in a flow state that you're functioning
with free will but if you just kind of
fall into it you just are along for the
ride well right now the biggest
underminer of free will is the left oh
this this guy he committed a crime
because of racism and sexism or or uh
or poverty
people are not responsible for the bad
that they do except for white christian
straight males they're responsible for
for all problems but everybody else is
not responsible the great underminer of
free will is the left
jelly cat says dennis have been
following you for years as long as i
follow tim tell this room of largely
unmarried without children to start
practicing what you preach they'll be
they'll be more credible i i did i i
made a strong case for getting married
guys and lady i did
she's married oh okay oh yeah
oh yeah
okay so you have to keep telling them
i'm trying
all right what do we got
stephen hartman says nuclear power
powers one fifth of homes in the u.s we
produce very little u308 and uf6
enriched u308 we source huge amounts
from russia currently who produces 40 of
the world's enriched uranium why are we
not using this carbon free energy shout
out to sput
okay it's by control
that was the argument that we offered
why is there nuclear power
would be a rare example of of of left
and right agreeing on something
what if we just had like little nuclear
reactors in our basement and every house
had its own power
like nuclear glass
it would be very little because nuclear
reactors are not gigantic and look at
how much they power yeah you'd have this
tiny little thing boiling water or
something and then spinning a turbine
it's like oh you got you gotta pour
water back in the in the tank keep it
going
i read a story once of a scuba diver got
sucked into an intake valve into a
nuclear plant totally fine because the
radiation doesn't permeate the water so
they were just swimming and they'd be
rescued oh that's fascinating people
think they're extremely dangerous i'll
tell you with uh like uh fukushima
nobody died but you get it from
radiation anyway well they got a big
spill it's bad but that's a natural
disaster that no one planned for right
well
it was an older reactor and it was a
tsunami
on the coast i mean it's the worst
it is nothing to be learned from it
it's very safe nuclear power well
the modern technologies and developments
have become much much better right
all right wimp low says mr prager will
you read something from the yellow pages
i think they're saying they like the
sound of your voice
oh that's funny how do you guys even
know what the yellow pages is oh yes of
course we're not that young
born
you want to hear my yellow pages story
do we have a minute yeah this is
priceless
so uh
nobody in my family
knew how to play an instrument or could
read music i refuse to do homework my
mother and father sit me down in the
kitchen i'm in eighth grade and they go
so what are you gonna do we don't let
you watch uh more than an hour of
television you won't do any homework
what are you going to do the rest of the
time
so one of us said i don't remember maybe
i'll study a musical instrument they
said great all right which one i didn't
even know names of musical instruments
so my mother says ah let's look in the
yellow pages
number one accordion that's how i
learned the accordion there you go
all right everybody
if you haven't already would you kindly
smash that like button subscribe to this
channel share the show and head over to
timcast.com if you sign up there at
about 11 p.m we'll be publishing the
members only after hours show we'll talk
a bit more about these issues that we're
getting a little spicy so we'll have
that up for you you can follow the show
at tim cast irl follow us on instagram
we post clips every day you can follow
me at tim cast and if you haven't
search for will of the people by tim
cast on youtube and check out the song
we did i know a lot of people haven't
actually heard it but it's actually a
short film and it's a political
statement so you might find it very
interesting if you pay attention to it
check that out we got more music on the
way and we're actually going to be
producing a few music music videos for
the album release which will be in mid
to late august uh dennis do you want to
shout anything out
yes thank you for the opportunity so
i do a a weekly
a fireside chat for prageru
and i think uh your your listeners would
love it i do a weekly podcast with this
young woman julie it's called dennis and
julie it's easily found
and of course there's all the work that
prageru is putting out we're trying to
make the case
for
as corny as it sounds truth and goodness
in a very sophisticated way
what about your books where can they get
those well that's easily found on amazon
any any any of my books uh i have a book
that explains america and the left it's
called still the best hope i have a book
on happiness and i have three volumes of
my
bible commentary two more to go
by the way this is my claim to fame well
not my only but a big one
costco has ordered 25 000 copies of my
next volume deuteronomy and as i always
say and it's not meant to belittle
costco i don't know if anyone at costco
can spell deuteronomy so the fact that
they ordered it i don't think i can yeah
no exactly i i don't think many
americans can it's the fifth of the five
first five books of my commentary anyway
uh
it's meant to change people's lives for
the better cool hillary clinton is uh
pretty popular at costco from the last
that i've seen is that true yes yes she
she was doing a book signing at costco
and um that's the latest video that we
saw from her but i have a youtube
channel it's uh youtube.com we are
change i just did a very interesting
video on the billionaire fight between
bill gates and elon musk that
perspective and what's really happening
and population control all that is being
discussed on youtube.com forward slash
we are change hope to join you there for
the conversation after this i had a bit
of a crisis while we were talking
earlier about jesus because the guy
basically was a jew and a devout jew and
spoke a lot about judaism but now the
people that worship the guy
aren't
well then duh you would be jew you would
also be like him like a jew like why
what the hell is going on let's save
that for the members only show that's a
that's a big question i love you guys
we'll see you there
i'm so fascinated to have dennis prager
here this evening because i have been
eyeballing his rational bible and we've
been going we went to a quaker meeting
we go to a baptist church sometimes we
go to a presbyterian church sometimes
and we've been bringing our co-workers
with us it's been great it's really been
an adventure since i've gotten married
so we are really excited to buy the
rational bible i'm really thrilled that
deuteronomy is coming out because that
is a book that is deeply misunderstood
by modern people oh god is so judgmental
how could he possibly make all these
rules how could he say all these
horrible violent things the god of the
old testament is so clearly different
from the god of the new testament so i'm
really looking forward to that kind of
thank you good when is when does that do
october awesome very cool okay we're
gonna get all those lined up anyway i am
separate it could be pre-ordered oh cool
i'm gonna do that then right after we're
done here and i also asked julie to come
on the show with us or told her to hit
me up and see if we can get her involved
talking to us your co-host anyway i am
sour patch lids you can follow me there
on twitter and mines.com as well
sourpatchlist.me
we will see all of you over at
timcast.com but if you want to help us
out and you're interested in the
cultural stuff we're developing check
out youtube.com cast castle the last two
episodes we have we're leaning heavily
into the uh scripted production we're
doing on the vlog this is always the
goal to get to the point where we're
we're basically trying to create like a
comedy version of what we do here and so
we had jamie killstein who's hilarious
we've been on the show a couple times
and he's going to be helping with
producing and writing sketches and doing
jokes at the cast castle because we want
to build culture and also again search
for will of the people by tim cast it's
a short film about four minutes long and
a song that i wrote that is very very
politically minded and you might you
might enjoy it or you might not comment
on the video let me know what you think
and if you really want to help and you
do like it share it we'll see you all
over at timcast.com thanks for hanging
out
you